[Música]
el matrimonio entre parejas del mismo
sexo recibió los votos necesarios en el
senado de Estados Unidos para ser
aprobado como una ley federal la
decisión también protegería las uniones
interraciales tenemos ampliación de
nuestro corresponsal en Washington
el presidente de Francia Manuel ya llegó
a Estados Unidos para su Segunda visita
de estado el mandatario tendrá
encuentros con empresarios este
miércoles y el jueves se reúne con Joe
biden se espera que entre otros temas
discutan la ley de inflación que Francia
considera proteccionista
en Perú congresistas opositores
presentaron la tercera moción de
vacancia contra el presidente Pedro
Castillo asegurando que el pedido Busca
salvar al país de un gobierno corrupto
con aspiraciones totalitarias es el
rechazo interno hacia el mandatario la
alianza del Pacífico quiso respaldarlo y
la próxima Cumbre se realizará en Lima
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano y del mundial soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en Estados
Unidos porque el senado aprobó un
proyecto de ley que protege el
matrimonio igualitario a nivel federal y
que ahora debe volver a la cámara de
representantes para su votación
definitiva la normativa promueve que el
Gobierno Federal reconozca el matrimonio
entre dos personas del mismo sexo si es
legal en el estado donde se casaron el
texto también reconoce la libertad
religiosa evitando que se pueda obligar
a instituciones religiosas como las
iglesias a celebrar estas bodas y que
estas pierdan beneficios o extensiones
Fiscales por no hacerlo Cristóbal
Vázquez corresponsal en la capital
estadounidense nos dio más detalles de
la decisión Del senado
fueron 61 votos a favor 36 en contra en
la cámara alta para codificar Es decir
para proteger el derecho Federal de los
estadounidenses a casarse las personas
del mismo sexo puedan casarse también se
aprobó el derecho a que personas de
razas de diferentes también puedan
casarse cuando lo deseen estas según
analistas una jugada que hacen los
demócratas Aprovechando que todavía
tienen mayoría tanto en cámara baja como
en cámara alta para poder pasar este
tipo de leyes que ya el presidente
Vallejo que apenas le llegara su
escritorio la firmaría republicanos
reaccionaron diciendo que pues no era
necesario pasar este tipo de leyes sin
embargo después de la decisión de la
Corte Suprema de Justicia este verano de
desconocer el derecho al aborto a nivel
nacional los demócratas han querido
tomar este tipo de medidas para proteger
derechos que según ellos son
fundamentales como el derecho al
matrimonio de el mismo sexo Hoy hubo
otra noticia Que centro la atención en
Estados Unidos porque un Jurado Federal
declaró culpable de Conspiración para
cometer sedición al fundador del grupo
de extrema derecha outs por su papel en
el asalto al Capitolio del 6 de enero en
2021 se trata de Stuart roads esto en
medio del juicio que inició el pasado 3
de octubre y en el que también fueron
absueltos otros integrantes de esa
organización el proceso buscaba
establecer el papel que desempeñaron los
acusados en su intento por detener el
proceso de ratificación en el congreso
de la Victoria electoral de Joe biden
el presidente Manuel llegó a Estados
Unidos en la que es su Segunda visita de
estado a Washington el mandatario se
reunirá el jueves con el presidente Joe
biden desespera se refiere a la ley de
reducción de la inflación que preocupa a
macron ante un posible retorno del
proteccionismo económico su visita será
además en un contexto internacional
álgido con la guerra de Rusia contra
Ucrania como telón de fondo
la vicepresidenta y ex mandataria de
Argentina Cristina Fernández de kirchner
acusado de presunta corrupción habló
este martes antes del juicio del 6 de
diciembre el que se conocerá El
veredicto en su contra Fernández que
sobrevivió a un intento de atentado el
primero de septiembre acusó a la corte
que la juzga de ser un pelotón de
fusilamiento Gabriel colchón nos cuenta
más
Este martes la vicepresidenta de
Argentina Cristina Fernández habló por
última vez en un juicio en el que se le
investiga por presunta corrupción en un
discurso difundido en directo desde el
senado acusó a la corte de ser un
tribunal de guerra jurídica debo decir
que esto más que un tribunal del delf
fue muy generosa creo en realidad es un
verdadero pelotón de fusilamiento la
vicepresidenta está acusada de haber
cometido delitos de asociación ilícita y
administración fraudulenta de fondos
públicos
el fiscal llegó luciani la señala de
estar inmersa en un auténtico sistema de
corrupción institucional y describe el
caso como la mayor operación de
corrupción que ha visto el país
señalamientos que Fernández de kirchner
siempre negó acusando los fiscales de
mentir y deformar los hechos se demostró
que todos y cada uno de las cosas que
habían sido acusación del fiscal eran
mentiras la vicepresidenta podría
enfrentar una pena de hasta 12 años de
prisión y la prohibición de ser elegida
en cargos públicos de por vida la
decisión final de los jueces se espera
para el próximo 6 de diciembre durante
el juicio sus opositores se reunieron
frente al tribunal de justicia de Buenos
Aires hace mucho que estamos esperando
una condena de aquellos que nos han
robado el futuro al mismo tiempo algunos
de sus partidarios estaban frente al
senado sea lo que sea para mí inocente
yo voy a estar apoyando a mi candidata
no vamos a permitir que la meta empresa
el primero de septiembre pasado la ex
mandataria sufrió una atentado después
de que un fiscal solicitara su condena
por presunta corrupción un hecho que
deja tres detenidos
continuamos en Perú porque el congreso
de esa nación le informó al presidente
Pedro Castillo sobre la nueva moción de
vacancia que presentó la oposición en su
contra argumentando una permanente
incapacidad moral se trata de la tercera
moción de destitución que es presentada
desde que Castillo está en la
presidencia en el pedido Los opositores
aseguran que buscan salvar a la nación
de un ejecutivo corrupto y que tiene
aspiraciones totalitarias
no se trata aquí del presidente no se
trata tampoco del Congreso finalmente se
trata del futuro del país se trata del
futuro de la Democracia se trata de no
entregarle nuestra nación a un gobierno
corrupto con ambiciones totalitarias
es el principal espíritu hoy en día y el
motivo de la fecha de presentación de
esta moción de vacancia Finalmente la
Cumbre de la alianza del Pacífico se
celebrará en Lima una medida de apoyo de
los miembros de esa organización al
presidente de Perú Pedro Castillo
recordemos que el congreso peruano le
impidió al mandatario viajar a México
donde estaba inicialmente previsto el
encuentro el movimiento llega en un
momento en que por primera vez los jefes
de estado de los cuatro países de la
alianza están alineados a la izquierda
y hay alerta en Perú Pero esta vez
porque el servicio nacional forestal y
de fauna Silvestre informó que al menos
13.869 aves marinas silvestres han
muerto por la influenza había tipo h5n1
en distintos puntos de la costa peruana
entre las especies afectadas se
encuentran Pelícanos piqueros marinos y
camanai las autoridades pidieron a los
ciudadanos que no se acerquen a las aves
marinas que estén heridas o muertas para
evitar más contagios a otras aves de
corral o mascotas esto el mismo día en
que el servicio nacional de sanidad
agraria de Perú informara que ya lucha
contra el primer bloque el primer brote
de esa influenza h5n1 detectado en una
finca de crianza de aves Hablamos ahora
del mundial de fútbol de Qatar porque
este miércoles se juega la jornada
número 11 y la tercera de la fase de
grupos América Latina tiene los ojos
sobre Argentina que se juega a su pase a
octavos Apolonia México explora frente
Arabia Saudita sus opciones para pasar a
la siguiente ronda del torneo bastante
dependientes de otros resultados Juan
pupiales enviado especial a catar nos da
más detalles de la jornada llegó el
momento de sacar la calculadora para los
grupos c y d que definen este día su
paso para los octavos de final por el
grupo c y el grupo de Argentina y el
grupo de México a la albiceleste le vale
ganar para asegurar su pase a los
octavos de final en ese partido contra
Polonia en esa final Como la definición
Leonel Messi la albi Celeste que cuenta
con todos sus efectivos para este
encuentro crucial les puede valer
también Incluso el empate para seguir
soñando en esta Copa Mundial de Qatar
2022 México por su parte se mide Arabia
Saudita conscientes de que solamente le
sirve ganar para seguir soñando en el
camino de este torneo por el grupo de
juega la campeona juega Francia que ya
se ha clasificada de los octavos de
final los franceses que se miden atunes
con la necesidad de garantizar al menos
un punto para asegurarse como primera de
grupo algo que puede ser crucial
teniendo en cuenta que este grupo el
grupo de Francia es el que se cruza con
el grupo de Argentina de México de
Polonia y Arabia Saudita en los octavos
de final Francia contra túnes como les
decimos en el otro partido de este grupo
que es el grupo de se mide en Dinamarca
contra Australia Australia con una
victoria garantiza su pase a los octavos
de final será una final porque todas las
opciones de Dinamarca pasan precisamente
también por ganar así que conoceremos ya
otros cuatro nuevos clasificados a estos
octavos de final en el mundial de Qatar
es todo por el momento en France 24
quédense con nosotros
[Música]